i'm going to read the story to you so uh
saudi uae leaders declined calls with
biden amid ukraine conflict this is a
hill story yesterday two days ago there
was some expectation of a phone call but
it didn't happen a u.s official told
the wall street journal regarding a call
between biden and saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman it was part of
turning
on the spigot of saudi oil uae leader
sheikh mohammed bin zayed also declined
a call from biden officials say the u.s
relations with the two gulf countries
have been strained over the biden
administration's lack of support in the
war in yemen
and the revived negotiation concerning
the iran nuclear deal saudi arabia has
also been pushing for legal immunity in
the u.s for crown prince mohammed who is
accused of killing a journalist in 2018.
so you got to realize foreign relations
is for people to pick up your calls to
talk to you
and and do something with you so these
guys when is the last time you heard a
story that somebody says
yeah u.s you know you're you're
historically been the greatest country
in the world the president wants to talk
to you you know what i'm going to keep
playing this xbox just tell by now call
him back later maybe send him a message
or something some flowers but we got
some things to do and then you hear the
questions people say
uh
your gas prices is all because of uh
russia okay if you can pull back what
you had the three pictures i send you
the two pig yeah
david if you can pull this one up and
they say gas prices is because of russia
okay
that's when biden was sworn in
okay gas prices were 2
30
240 do you see that that's when he was
sworn in okay
putin invaded
when gas prices were at 351
this is not a russia thing folks
this went from 240
to 350 that's a buck 10 on 240 that's 45
it went up in a year and a half a little
over a year and a half two years
during the administration is that a
byproduct of what's going on there now
if you look at it now it went from 351
to 412 and it's going to get higher uh i
see this thing getting higher i've
already made my prediction seven eight
months ago right the gas prices are
gonna hit ten bucks a gallon uh and some
are even saying right now it's gonna hit
15 bucks a gallon by the way there's a
video can you go to the next slide so
they can see some of the pictures this
is glendale california 669.
go to the next one this is beverly hills
can you zoom in a little bit so people
can't see it it's 7 29 for a 91
in beverly hills there's a gas station
right across the street john reed was
telling the story yesterday in the pdp
podcast prep meeting he said the guy is
telling me fill up your gas tank now
while it's 4 19. it's going to be 490 by
midnight and by later on tonight fill it
up right now there's a person that did a
video
standing in front of a gas station
recording a video
seeing the prices go
401 402 403 404. for
what i'm saying live they're recording
it while they're filling up the tank the
prices per gallon is going up while it's
filling up the tank
craziness it's like a stock you're the
gas price on the tank it's like a stock
market the stock market so the guys are
telling you buy and fill up your tank
now
we should teach our kids supply and
demand can you go back to the biden
chart real quick
thank you t take a look at the immediate
you see how the curve immediately jumps
after the inauguration pat it's like
real steep and then it kind of levels
out the reason it did that was this okay
no more keystone and limiting american
drilling that creates what a shortage in
supply actually reduces supply which
increases price so the economy works
exactly the way but that was him cow
towing to the greens on keystone
pipeline and drilling in the u.s and you
saw immediately upon being inaugurated
he put pressure on the american people
and gas prices immediately it just jumps
up and then it's a more gentle increase
until the big fun starts with ukraine
who who hurts this the most who's
hurting right now the average average
the average the the low income people
obviously you know i'll go one step
further the lower cost housing is
farther from city center but the jobs
are in city center the commuting times
hits the middle and lower class worse
than it does the upper class and so when
this happens you're hurting the people
that can least afford it
why is it that
politicians
who create policies to help the low and
middle income
are the ones that end up directly and
indirectly hurting the community that
they claim that they want to help can
you go to my twitter profile yesterday
bernie sanders said uh
something about uh how much money the
billionaires and whatever millionaires
made in the last uh
uh
12 to 18 months during the pandemic i
don't know if you can pull it up anyways
i i responded back to him saying this is
a again byproduct of uh i'll just read
it to you right here since you're i'll
i'll
printing the money now here's what i
told him so he said this is a this is
oligarchy this is greek this is
callousness last year over two million
go to what he had to say go go to his
tweet and then you'll go back right
there yeah yeah this is callousness last
year over two million can you zoom in a
little bit so audience can see it over
two million people worldwide died of
hunger at the same time the world's 2.2
uh 2755 billionaires saw their net net
worth or wealth go up 5 trillion
from 8.6 trillion to 13.8 trillion this
is why we need a tax on wealth okay now
go back in this is my responses three
parts i said that's what happens when
you print money and give handouts to
people who don't know how to manage
money they buy products from companies
started by entrepreneurs money flows up
stimulus money rolled up to billionaires
they'd love another round bernie go a
little lower and then i said step number
one of helping low and middle income
families to teach them how money works
teach them how to create an additional
source of income teach them to read the
right books instead of watching netflix
which politician is talking about that
today no one go below and the last one
why not because vote because those votes
may start thinking for themselves if we
truly care about the loan middle-income
families let's help them graduate the
poverty mindset instead of being stuck
there that's what great leaders do they
leave you better than they found you so
if you enjoyed this little segment from
the podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]